i'll start with this uh i really enjoyed
what if on disney plus
right so i'm curious have you guys
watched it and have you pitched the
studio or pitched marvel on um the three
of you doing an episode where perhaps mj
gets bitten by the spider or ned gets
bit by the spider and the three of you
are able to do this in a voiceover
that'd be fun
yeah
i always watch the episode with the
spider-man and the zombies the zombies i
haven't seen it
i need to watch it i need to watch it
it's unlike me to not
keep up to date with the marvel stuff i
just one thing i've missed it's very fun
but i think that's a great idea so they
has been pitching an idea for a disney
plus movie which is called the teachers
of midtown high yeah which is like a
scenario i don't know if my idea as much
as the internet's idea take the credit
for it or maybe it was john watts idea
because
we kind of have bonus features and yeah
yeah and i think that would be a great
center already that but i would love to
see
teachers of midtown
just their mundane teacher things and
being
dealing and living in a we could cameo
in it every now and then in a superhero
universe you know we could be like
alumni that come back to the school and
give speeches about stuff it'd be great
i i am sure that there are people over
the last year or two that have asked you
to spoil or tell you tell them things
about this movie and i was curious
who is the person that you least
expected to
ask you for information that i actually
asked you for information
kevin feige actually asked me some
information
he knows everything everybody doesn't
need to ask him
yeah
i don't think that's true yeah that
sounds like a lie
guys i was joking kevin feige knows
everything about these movies
um
someone who asked me to spoil it i don't
know i feel like everybody yeah everyone
pretty much every morning
that's what i've learned yeah for sure
i've met like a few basketball players
like who have been really excited about
it
yeah yeah
by the way i didn't even i didn't start
with this but i i want to just
compliment you guys i saw the opening 38
minutes and it's spectacular
you know it's so good um i know fans are
going to absolutely love it how long
have you guys actually known did you
know making the first movie that you
were building towards the multiverse
like how long have you guys known what
this movie was really going to be
at least a couple years yeah
yeah yeah but no one did yeah
i didn't even know what the first movie
was about when i was making the first
movie
accurate you know i was we were so in
the dark right
but now we really know and we're part of
the team the creative team and you know
they trust our opinions and they ask us
questions and stuff so we've been
sitting on this secret for a very long
time
long longer than i would have liked i've
heard about it i was like
okay cool but like that's probably not
not going to happen
for sure yeah so later they'll pitch
something else because that didn't work
out yeah
yeah later we're now following
for a long time there was a craven movie
that was going to be the third movie
because
things weren't working out and all sorts
of different stuff and john pitched me
this craven movie which actually was
really cool i i don't want to talk about
it in case that movie ends up happening
down the line but it was fun
um i wouldn't uh the thing about
the spider-man movies and all the mcu
movies in general is they're all going
to have these kick-ass action scenes
right i get that but my favorite stuff
with you guys in all these movies is
just the dialogue scenes between the
three of you it's so well done and the
like the just the dynamics between your
relationships so i am curious if you
could talk a little bit about filming
those scenes and working with john to
like sort of get those right because i
think that's the stuff that everyone
wants you know what i mean it's those
dialogue moments
yeah i mean there's there's a heart and
soul in the movie yeah you know sure and
john's super collaborative and
allows for us to bring whatever ideas or
thoughts we have about the characters i
mean because we have lived with them for
quite a while so yeah um we we know a
little something but um but i think it's
really special because we care about the
characters so much and what they go
through
um and like i said john has a great way
of like
taking
all of our ideas or things that we bring
to the table and then
actually some somehow finding a way to
make it make sense and put it in
to something that actually
is a scene yeah
um but yeah
those are my favorite scenes too they're
my favorite scenes too absolutely i
think you've really like especially in
this movie come into your own words in
terms of improvising oh for sure lots of
jacob's stuff in this film is like
off-the-cuff improvised lines and like a
lot of our reactions is probably very
genuine
uh i would imagine the thing i i think
is that the everyone watching these
movies at home will see all like the
film and think it was just easy and
stuff but i don't think enough people
realize what it really takes to make a
movie of this scale and scope and so for
each of you could you sort of share what
you'd like more people to know about
what it really takes to make a movie
like this
i mean when i say there's like blood
sweat and tears i'm not exaggerating you
know
making these films is incredibly tough
and physical especially when you're
playing a character like spider-man uh
we all believe so much in these
characters and we give it 110 i know
in my fight scene with the goblin like i
bust my hand up i like my knuckles all
bloodied and and you know we were really
going for it we were putting everything
into it and i remember on the last day
of shooting that fight scene when john
said cut
uh willem and i both just collapsed to
the floor and just because we were
exhausted and we just had given him
everything i remember just chugging red
bulls
to like try and keep my energy going
um and i remember rachel o'connor's son
came into first a d that day and it was
actually really nice because with this
how old do you reckon he was like 12
maybe and he was like first a d for us
and even though it was ridiculous
his energy and his excitement gave us
like a second wind to really give this
action sequence it's like full potential
uh so that was a lot of fun i think it's
always just the amount of the people
that work on a movie like this yeah for
sure you know we were also doing it
during covid yeah so that created a
whole new set of challenges and
there were so many villains that had to
appear and scheduling and i don't know
how
ads do what they do but the fact that
any of it made sense and was able to
yeah
dave vegas
made sense i mean there's so many people
behind the scenes that work so hard to
make this a reality
every single thing everything you see
somebody is behind it and somebody's put
really a lot of love and care into it uh
because they care as much as we i mean
we're all fans
you know so um i think
beyond ourselves there's just so much
that you don't see and then after in
post-production so many people are
building these images and making them
look beautiful so it's uh it's really
all over the world yeah it's a labor of
love from so many different people